[Music]
oh very far
it was my wheel I took that banjo and I
put it on my car like a wheel came out
here to do another podcast where Sam did
a much better intro and I Spit my
Copenhagen and that's all right I forgot
the rhyme song got maybe a a B structure
I've read but school I drink my beer
with a okay
[Laughter]
welcome back guys Sam did the intro
today and I gotta say we should probably
have you do it again cool fine intro
don't take it personally but each song
is gonna be about you okay it's just
it's just the talk of the town Jake
you're such a personality we all know
and love really and you know I think
these songs will help kind of just like
you know the reinforce that that myth
you know behind you man the myth the
lose your true origins your story your
legend etc so that's one contribute have
you met anybody with a truly strong
Texas accent oh yeah yeah but it's
different then I don't know if I don't
think I can do it justice to like try to
repeat it but there's a lot of cuz I
know that it's like a West Texas accent
yeah there's like a wish Texas Sam
you like that microphone being really
far away from real uh yeah I do the
strongest ones though are the closer you
get to Louisiana Oh interesting the
strong
it becomes more like like a little
slower and well the Louisiana accent is
a fine example of the accents of the
United States it's unique in its own
right and it's got all this heritage in
it the French heritage in it and yeah a
Cajun mm-hmm oh yeah just like the
lyrics to the next song that's I put my
take out in my bag
I want my slurp with the rag what is the
origin of the slurp we came up with it
when we were I think it was just like
that accent just like very like liquid
and we realized that oh it's because the
accent comes from having all this like
chewing tobacco in your mouth Wow well
we got who do we have on the podcast
today should we go around introduce
ourselves
hey I'm Nico you might know me from such
things as corridor digital dope intro
well I'm Dean and you might also know me
from such things that you might not
actually know me from there things like
corridor digital yeah hi my name is Sam
uh I know this is my first podcast and
I'm really excited to see what we dive
into well we got Dean on and I figured
you know people have been asking for
other people on the cast and you know we
had Brett last week I figured what the
hell let's appreciate of guy janki's
podcast on the Internet I swear actually
before we get into Dean because I do
want to talk about Dean number one first
thing this is a sponsored podcast so
later in this podcast I'm gonna randomly
cut and it's gonna go to story box and
when you say when you least expect it
now that might not make a lot of sense
or be important to you but if you're a
filmmaker I got to tell you as somebody
who uses story blocks in our content
creation process consider story blocks
and
the other thing is I can't remember now
but it's important but it's important I
will say that it's role that we got for
a sponsored podcast yeah we got a
sponsor I mean we haven't had a sponsor
in like a year
probably because we didn't do podcasts
like we've been doing him again
consistently and people have been
enjoying them you know we had a we had a
nice young woman email us and say how
she listens to him when she's doing
stuff around her house and it was nice
really kind email we've had people say
in the comments how they like just
hanging out with us um so you know I
figured this is a good time to
decompress and talk about the things
we're working on and talk about things
that inspire us and unemotionally sure
and then also um oh that was the other
thing I know guys this is one of the
janki's podcasts on the internet but we
embrace Doby around here and I do want
to say one day you're gonna miss this
because when we move into Studio 3 we're
gonna redo this space a little bit and
it's gonna be it's gonna have you're not
gonna see you know the the art that if
someone sent us or like this blue bin
back okay be honest I'm genki genki
podcasts or when people like do a zoom
call or Skype call and they record the
Skype resume audio and put that into the
yeah as when that is what we were doing
so we have not we have done that no but
you remember when we were all in
quarantine yeah the first quarantine
podcast was total Jack I'm a complete
hypocrite what do I do
I guess this is one of these like things
were working on isn't a these emotional
issues take that I guess and you say oh
wow I guess I guess we did that oh wow I
guess we did that why do you better do
Paris cuz now I feel like every episode
of Sam Harris's podcast yeah like you
know he's calling somebody on zoom' or
like a potato potato there was at one
period of time when I really like was on
early cell phones and like but every had
kind of switched over to cell phones so
everybody's calls are just like 12
kilobytes per second javi oh yeah
remember that yeah ah have you used a
landline recently anybody
they sound so clear and crisp like
there's like no one using it like so the
bandwidth is just like he's entire cable
just for your one voice that's cable to
yourself
yeah goes all the way to the other
person just like the good old days one
ethernet cable just for your voice data
for the phone enthusiast telephone
enthusiasts I'm a hi-fi phone enthusiast
I have no idea what you guys are talking
about oh this is a perfect segue Dean
when were you born I was born in the
night is February 9th 1997 really seven
landline is when you dig a hole in the
ground and you bury a phone and you have
to go on bury it every time your usual
that's why they got rid of them you know
when you plug your phone into charge
imagine if the cable was a couple miles
long and went to a company yeah I tried
once I didn't get it to work and I
didn't realize the wire has to be taught
like has to be a tight wire like you
can't just be a loose string you can't
just hire a string to the bomb mechanics
vibrations yeah I can
so here's how you see something doing
that they like the string needs to be
tight to the other can yeah but this is
something that kids do Nikko well I know
but it's like what's the point talking
to chuck we're splitting up two groups
there's good kids and bad kids or smart
kids and dumb kids smart kids have the
taught spring really yes I'm gonna take
notes on this and when my kids start
doing it I'm gonna be like hey hey is
using the tight string you're being a
bit of a loose top being a loose string
do you guys are a tribe person in the
studio uh I believe so yeah so we call
him young Dean except for being uh
whenever Peters here I had become the
second youngest yeah that's crazy how
does it feel feels uh feels pretty cool
I like I like being the young guy in the
in the in the group um you know I like
because I feel like throughout my sort
of career and being around people I've
been I've been around a lot of older
people so they sort of tribute like a
peer but then I get to like learn stuff
from people so I feel like for anybody
out there who's like you know trying to
out there and learn stuff be around
people older than you're older than
yourself you know yeah yeah that's good
that's how he's the way that I've come
to learn a lot as well I remember in
college when they had us on the track
team all the guys that were like seniors
you know you're you're 18 in they're 22
and they seemed like oh those guys are
so old but same thing you know it was
like we were peers but at the same time
there's all these different things that
I could learn um you know it made me a
better better athlete and a better
person and yeah that's good I'm yeah I
mean well that's one of the reasons why
we you know we had you come in
originally because I kind of saw that
perspective that you had and well you
know what somebody in the comments the
other day was like what's with what's
with Jake he's like this old guy that's
like around all these young kids all the
time like what's what's up with that
dude it's creepy I was like should I
comment and like say that we're all kind
of the same age or so you are yeah yeah
no I mean by like a couple of months not
by like well currently the studio is
like a very even gradient right now yeah
yeah
so I don't know that's a funny comment
but that's from like a 12 year old
you know maybe yeah I think just a
perspective of the age 12 year olds who
sees you they're like this is like a
fully grown man that's what I think
every day and I look in the mirror and
I'm like no yeah right yeah yeah I
always had a picture of my dad with me
when I was a baby
oh yeah holy [ __ ] looks like your clone
which it yeah I do look like a clone my
dad but everything it looks like an
older version of you Nico it's like my
dad is younger than me with pictures
taken I got a question about dads do you
how often do you catch yourself now
doing something that your dad would have
done or saying something in a way that
you're dead all the whole time yeah yeah
it's it's real it's real I mean you
don't turn into your parents you're
definitely your own person but their
influence on you
it's perpetual and constant and Union
you realize it's like wait a minute hold
on that was the case that's the case for
me and that was the case for them that
was the case for the person before them
and that goes all the way back yeah
whenever yeah it's like a mean game of
telephone you wanna make that string as
loose as possible apparently yeah your
parents can't hear what you're saying
you guys tried doing that by the way the
Kansas strings thing like have yes I may
actually attempt no I never did it
successfully we had a loose spring
because loose stringers huge thanks to
story blocks for sponsoring today's
podcast if you guys are interested
there's a link in the description below
story box is our go-to over here at
corridor whether it's a video or an
After Effects template or an audio sound
by story blocks allows us to download
content anytime usually it's in 4k it's
constantly updated so there's always new
stuff on there and put that into our
video even if you just have your own
Instagram profile and you're not a
professional creator story blocks is
something you're gonna want to consider
because you can post what you get from
that site anywhere so if we're making a
YouTube video or we're making a
commercial and it has to go across
multiple social media platforms we know
that whatever we download from there is
safe to use for those purposes so if you
guys are interested consider a
subscription to story blocks just go to
story box comm slash corridor cast or
click the link in the description of
this video
happy creating yeah I mean I used to
play kick-the-can
did you ever play that game
sophisticated game no one can make a
game yes there's rules just like
baseball it's not you're like oh what do
you just say this just ball this ball
flies around randomly and you get two
bases that's pretty much baseball soccer
even less rules look keep the can you
put the can in the middle of a circle
and then you draw a circle around the
can and then somebody stands inside of
it or maybe a few people and then the
other team has to kick the can out of
the circle without getting tagged mmm so
you want to make the circle big enough
where they have a chance but small
enough where it's competitive that
sounds like fun
it is like it can hum note go pro ana
can I kick the can yeah it's kind of a
miniseries like let's take dumb like
yeah dumb game dumb games and loose
string these dreams yeah and it's like
alright we're taking this seriously it's
rock paper scissors it's kick-the-can
hopscotch sharks and minnows and we just
flip the table in front of all of it
dumb hop Scott I'm dumb sharks and
minnows competitive competitive adult
continent even a real game I don't get
hopscotch honestly I never got it like
they always painted it like on the
recess like tarmac and like rock and
really knows the rules there wasn't hard
yeah
so you just jump apparently I'm the
recess expert here because OJ got scotch
scotch at least this is the way that we
used to play it it's very competitive
there's a lot of rules okay it's like
horse but Foursquare jumping okay and so
you have to mimic what the other person
does mm-hmm and so you go through the
squares so it's like one foot one foot
yeah yeah exactly and then you is there
still the the mechanic the mechanic
throwing a stone onto the hopscotch
squares which signifies an end point or
something like that I saw that somewhere
in like a no black and white no the way
they we used to play it was you just you
draw him up and then you go along them
and then you pick like which foot and
how you go about the combin
and there's all these mysterious things
the numbers on the square sometimes
numbers on that's to indicate which
square it is wait so could I get
confused if I did like a triple backflip
into the next like somebody would have
to do that yeah you can you might
wittingly you instantly I mean if you
could do a triple backflip in a
hopscotch game you definitely win
there's like 0.0001 percent of people
who even compete yeah but that's what
makes it competitive well that's a list
of top of the total impact hot
kick-the-can
olympic hopscotch olympic sharks and
minnows you wanna know what a real tight
string game is tetherball tetherball is
a quality tether ball you can tether
ball can get dangerous yeah
that rope wrapped around your neck you
play with their big kids yeah and it's
like oh dude you want to play with the
sixth graders this is gonna be rough
they still play Red Rover in school
what's that one no I think yeah you
throw it over though no no you to charge
the line of kids an attempt to break
through their arms oh yeah yeah I mean I
hope so probably not it's probably
banned on the list of bait how about
struck we're different we have one in
the in the Bronx called hops which was
you had to it was literally just your
holding ball and you're passing it to
somebody and you have to be jump catch
it and throw it while you're off the
ground yeah and so you're what is that
one that's just called hops just hops
like simplified no that's like you can
only throw it when you're in the air
yeah you can only catch and throw while
you're in the air so basically you gotta
like your feet have to be off the ground
yeah that's really interesting back into
this through and take notes sorry
where's another one a whole Foursquare
yeah I like Foursquare that one's pretty
simple you're basically just bouncing a
ball it's like if you catch the ball
before he hits the ground they lose it's
kind of like ping pong yeah that's what
kids games mostly arts just you take a
normal sport and you replace the ball
with a big rubber ball
baseball baseball olympic football and
then you specifically don't you try and
hit the person with the ball to get them
out you gotta care oh it Adam yeah yeah
so that's baseball but throwing the ball
players rules different you don't call
directly at them in baseball yeah yeah
he'll take people oh really okay that
makes sense yeah you have to be connect
that little ball would be yeah it'd be a
hard hit yeah
you know when we were filming tactical
three loads out in Texas back in like
March or February or whenever that was
yeah Freddy is talking about like
getting people together for a weekend
baseball game in the coronavirus it and
like that mythical sunny day weekend
baseball game lives in my mind is this
thing I year and for now dude I'm so
down for that yeah so down for some
weekend base it's a weekend baseball out
by the lake yeah Karthi mark yeah it's
true down there just bringing guns he
don't get mugged is there a spot in LA
where we could try to do the Viking
funeral pyre thing for real no literally
nowhere unless the ocean see what is
there space in it later we can try the
Viking funeral pyre thing for real we're
get to shoot a flaming arrow onto a boat
tomorrow you could do that in my
neighborhood if you guys state that has
more more water yeah the water a person
ratio here's a little too low for them
yeah yeah we get all our water from
freaking Colorado yeah go to Colorado
yes so fast sending burning boats to any
water source here travel to coast you
could probably find a spot no I don't
know you could find a spot and get away
with it but it would be illegal isn't
the Salton Sea still around oh yeah you
could probably do it there hasn't hasn't
evaporated yet yeah yeah yeah I went
there I and I was in it was horrible
there's people who live there yeah they
live with it every day it's like imagine
like you know that fish like Chinese
restaurant dumpster smell yeah when
you're in a really grody alley like yeah
just the world smells like it there yeah
there's some
different about those like desert
California people off the radar damn
desert dwellers well they have a myth
behind them too
you know it's like there's that mythic
like how do they survive it's like wait
myth or meth yes there's a low blow
there's a hole the meth rates are really
high it's okay there's a whole place in
New York
you're Spencer's parents house called
little Borrego trailers now or across
the desert oh wow and it's just a bunch
of people just living out in this like
area what kind of games do you think
they play they probably play oh well
shoot each other with bottle rockets
that's a fun one yeah roman candles yeah
they're definitely playing that out
there things like you know you hear the
speak inception of like California is
like you know you got the coastal cities
like Los Angeles the San Francisco and I
guess throw San Diego in there you know
it's like yeah most of California is
still like the Wild West
I mean I guess he had like the farmland
in the middle or whatever but like you
go north and east of LA and it's
straight-up desert people and nothing
for miles and you can you set up bombs
in those hills I mean the US government
sets off bombs in those hills and
notices I mean that's everything Nico's
talking about Southern California yeah
that's everything south of the Central
Valley now for those of you don't know
Central Valley of California
it's a breadbasket of America in
addition to the Midwest but Central
Valley goes from north of LA all the way
up to four hours north of San Francisco
and it's just agriculture all trees and
cows yeah it's like are they any trees
actually or trees oh yeah yeah it's
interesting cuz most of Cal you know
like you're saying you think California
liberals but mostly California is red
you know yeah yeah I mean most of
everyone is real and it's just that the
big cities yeah congregate there's more
predominantly
left organizations and people there
which you know makes sense you know you
have people living in much closer
relation to one another they tend to
make decisions based behind that
perspective and you know yeah well the
thing that always strikes me about like
you know the whole red and blue divide
it's like when people talk about like
electoral college and like popular vote
not kind of stuff it's like you gotta
remember our food it comes from the
unpopulated areas where she's like one
dude in like a couple square miles of
Agriculture and like if you don't
represent some of that landmass
correctly then you throw off the
political representation of the people
that grow all the food that's kind of an
essential thing to remember and then
build all the houses make all the steel
and yeah almost bring all the equipment
across the country and trucks and cars
and railroads you know it almost makes a
good argument for like all right well
state level is almost still too big for
governing in a way because of that split
but but at the same time it's like they
work off of each other though you know
what I mean like you can't just say
here's the rules for Los Angeles County
and then like take a County further like
east to here and do it and have them run
independently because there's so much
involved and also like the more thing
about a - it's like the whole value
system in in cities where everything's
like super expensive it's like the
runoff from large cities from a monetary
standpoint can fund so much stuff
incredible not in that City I you know
like there's some there's like it
doesn't seem like surplus the people
living there yeah but - literally
everywhere else it's just like bountiful
look at look at any major metropolitan
area San Antonio being a relevant one in
my life recently I mean I moved to
outside of that area and from basically
there's a 1604 loop right which you guys
know cuz that's kind of where we were
mmm and then outside of that then
there's the 46 and then it keeps going
and it's like there's this giant ring
around the entirety of San Antonio
especially on the north and west side
that is all just economic surplus from
San Antonio did you guys see yourselves
living in a city when you were young
like
think you're gonna be in I guess - Jake
you're kind of no longer in a city
situation now but yeah I'm definitely in
the country now but I I mean I moved
here you know lived here for 12 years
I definitely like had my night before I
came here I was like I wouldn't you know
wouldn't be cool and I got a lot I got
that when I was here for sure
but I don't know I guess I never thought
about it when I was a young young like
thinking about imagining myself in the
city or not I mean I just wanted to play
major league baseball and call it a day
what's the best part of being a city
slicker versus being a country yokel ah
city slickers well I mean you got
everything in close proximity which is
obvious but also you know I mean there's
there's just a lot you can engage with
like from like everything from you know
what you want to do with your life to
who you want to be around to the ideas
and the people that you want to engage
with to like the type of food that you
want to eat type of music you want to
hear whatever there's just there's just
a lot more options when you start to
move to a rural area it's like there's
only there's only so much of each slice
of that that you can get mm-hmm and some
of its few and far between but so that's
the best thing about living in the city
I mean the best thing about living in
the country for me at least is like the
quiet the sort of more consistent way of
life you know one thing that I've been
thinking about since since I moved there
and you know I was thinking about this
before which is you know I've been
wanting to move for a while I've been
thinking about this but it's been more
present in my mind since I moved you
come to a city like LA and you see
everyone just running around all the
time
everyone's running here everyone's
running there everyone's doing this
every was doing that and they
just you know there's a there's a
difference between progress and just
like running around just for because you
have to the rat race yeah the rat race
exactly and so it's definitely more
prevalent where I am now in Texas seeing
a little bit more laid-back way of life
and seeing like you know people just
generally aren't interested in like you
know making a mountain out of a molehill
in terms of like well we need to do this
and we need to do that and people should
have this and people shouldn't have that
and like perpetuating this constantly of
just like nothing is okay we need to do
X Y & Z or you know things are fine
things are good but we still you know we
can make it better if we do X Y & Z it's
like the perspective is more like well
no life is good things can be better and
we will make progress to do that but at
the same time like we're not going to be
radical about it or we're not going to
be like just hyper attentive about it
mm-hmm
and that has good and bad things you
know it's it's good in the sense that it
keeps you a little bit removed from like
you know being being right in the heat
of things being right in the heat of a
conversation but at the same time it's
bad because you don't really do anything
you don't really have an interest or
have it have a say or desire to have an
interest or say until it starts to
affect you hmm
and so those things have a balance but
yeah that's that's definitely it's good
for respective it sounds like though I
think so yeah just just about when I get
tired of being in in my back in the
woods all day I come out here and it's
like wow yeah
do the amount of graffiti that's
starting to like pop up around here I
guess let me clarify I don't mean like
murals or people doing like nice big
pieces I'm talking about somebody just
like splattering paint on the side of my
building you're talking about tagging I
think we know what you're so yeah it's
crazy hey like it's just this parts it's
exploding man people are okay I'm glad
you brought this up because I wanted it
I said hey maybe we could talk about the
explosion of crime violence because whoa
how did you guys look about what
happened over fourth of July weekend
like all over the place that was like
there was like hundred and fifty
shootings and my hair and there was 50
over here and there was 60 there like
every sitting here and all over the
country all over the country and it's
just like Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam like you
know seven year old girls getting shot
and like eight year old kids getting
shot
like just heinous heinous stuff and you
know tagging is kind of a you know it's
a sub sect of that anger I think like
it's like people are just straight-up
Unleashed right now but I don't know
have you seen you've seen more of it in
the city oh I mean yeah it's like
pulling up all over the place like every
day is a new tag like around here and
just it just seems like there's like
complete disregard for like the
community you know it's like oh here's a
building or somebody tried to like clean
it up they try to paint it they try to
make it look nice splatter my name on
the side of it you know right and just
ruin it when you yeah I mean but it's
like if if Society has failed you then
why should you give a [ __ ] about Society
know exactly the perspective that yes
people are doing that and like and I can
see right now we're a block bike yes
side he failed me and sitting around
doing nothing for the past five months
just getting screwed by this pandemic
yeah I feel like that's that's those
like unforeseen consequences of the
long-term lockdown which is like you
know I have conversations with people
where they're like you know but we just
got a you know just be sure that sort of
we lock down we what's the term with the
curve flatten the curve but we flatten
the curve yeah you know everything's
gonna be alright everybody's gonna get
their check whatever but it's like
there's also just the psychological
consequences of being unemployed for you
know what are we going on for five
months now and like yeah it's just not
and also the you know they sent out the
twelve hundred dollar check and then
that was it so you know it's like so
people just been sitting in their house
like barely able to feed themselves it's
like a very focused like [ __ ] you laser
beam also or like oh yeah it's like you
working there as hotly
being in the service industry like the
retail industry like it's like your yeah
[ __ ] you you know your goods and every
else is fine
more or less I'll even get to work from
home cool cushy don't commute anymore
there's no traffic easy and that I don't
feel like I am getting screwed I can't
pay my rent and so it's like there's not
like a very specific strip like 10% of
the population that's just like taking
the brunt of it you know so where do you
think this goes I mean here's the
question you get hurt immunity
eventually yeah are we are we waiting
for a vaccine or are we just gonna
[ __ ] tough it out and like I don't
know f-bombs have you the poopy word
yeah I think we're going for her to
mmunity I don't know I mean like I from
what I've read like a vaccine is just
not gonna get here in time before we hit
herd immunity like it's just it's they
say this is the thing with like
respiratory like diseases is that
there's so hard to contain because like
it just it spreads may morph to
respiratory droplets so like you know
it's just one per like we could lock
down the whole country one person
spreads it and we're back yeah so you
know here's an interesting thing that
doesn't I don't know why this isn't
getting talked about more but like I've
been thinking about this for the last
three weeks like why aren't they talking
about this so cases have risen
substantially mm-hmm but the death as of
June 7 I know you're going with it yeah
June 7th we were at 18,000 cases roughly
a day you know fourth of July weekend
massive spikes 55,000 cases a day so
that's triple almost the death rates
have continued to go down and further
down and further down now they're
they're going between you know they were
in June at the same time that there was
20,000 18,000 cases a day you had
between a thousand and five hundred
cases a day
now our spikes are around 600 and our
lows are around 200 deaths a day sorry
so I actually read an article about this
this morning but nobody know so for the
last three weeks this has been happening
consistently yeah but it's in the
evidence is up you know it's all over
the place that the reporting is all over
the place when you look at the actual
medical like from the CDC stuff yeah but
there's not happening conversation is
what I've read 28 you bring this up
because like I literally just read an
article on this and you're right people
aren't really talking about it but maybe
it's starting to like bubble up here and
there so one of the things is that the
people getting infected now are younger
um
like cases and like nursing homes and
things that have gone down significantly
huh whereas cases in the general
population which is younger have gone up
but the death rates also a lot lower for
younger people right versus for older
people so you you can't have people more
people getting infected but the death
rate stays low because the people that
are you know immunocompromised or
at-risk like they're the ones that are
staying safe so okay well okay so
there's two things happening then people
that are immunocompromised are at risk
are being more safe mm-hmm the people
that were not as safe at the beginning
when no one knew kind of how to handle
it died unfortunately and now the virus
is spreading to lower ages mm-hmm I
guess that makes sense biologically I
mean that's how any virus would would
function yeah and then the it's also
like a two-week leg on deaths too
infections is it hmm so cuz you you get
the disease and then you you kick around
for two so maybe that's another reason
why people have been withholding I guess
comment on that because we don't know I
mean who knows maybe next week that's
the thing with this next week it could
be different
yeah sure there's no way it doesn't
shoot up more than it has you know cuz
it's just but if it doesn't it then you
know it's like what is going on then you
know right like once again yeah you know
more young people are getting infected
than before but like you expectedly some
sort of a spike in at least two weeks
from now we'll see but there's that
whole way keep your eyes out on a death
spike and coronavirus
guys I mean there's no studies that
happened like sorry say right at the
beginning where they did like in general
samples of populations and like the like
oh [ __ ] like 4% of people in LA have
already had it based on our random
sampling of people yeah and then like
every just stopped doing that research
and just stopped investigating that or
writing about it like yeah what happened
there like everything okay yeah you know
it's weird it's weird that a half a
million people actually have it in LA
but we didn't know that and then like
whatever you guys feel like one of the
weirdest s-- or most challenging parts
of going through this is also we're
experiencing the breakdown of you know
traditional media or meet like
centralized narratives of media so it's
like this is the first yeah you know I
can't think of anything that that's
happened on this level
that we've gone through with the social
media influence and all this stuff where
it's like you just there's no authority
anymore yeah you don't know what's
happening even if it's like even if the
authority is miss misguided in some
respect it's like we don't we can't
agree on what's even going on you know
yeah oh man I've been yeah go ahead
let me say it's like places like the CDC
are like so neutered that's like the
calluna just give me like a brochure for
the doctor's office it says like wear a
mask and like try to stay on six feet
away from somebody's like thanks CDC
like yeah I know and like half the stuff
is just you're pulling out of your but
anyways like there's no one who's like
okay here's the studies and here's what
we've done and here's the act of next
steps we're taking like there's no one
like in a leadership position to do that
but maybe suppose there's not really
anybody in leadership positions anymore
and it's hitting society differently all
over yeah - hey like for example Comal
County were where I'm at had like 20
cases zero deaths total mmm and then
like literally one County over San
Antonio County it's like stories totally
different yeah
hears stories totally different death
rates in Texas compared to California
totally different that rates in
California versus New York totally
different hmm
you know and some of that some of the
decentralization is some of the strength
of America but also sometimes it's you
know it's
this is it's hard to have any and I
don't know if the decisions on like how
we should proceed should be made at like
even a state level much less a federal
level hmm
because it's it's so specific to
communities it's really unique to how
like the black lives matter movement
flared up like right in the middle of
all this to is just such a weird
cultural moment not weird but like a
unique cultural moment like people's
mind states and like yeah the state of
America at the moment yeah I think
there's like they're so caught it's so
causative you know like I really feel
like that that wouldn't have gone off
the way it did if people weren't already
you know unemployed locked down like
every angry you know it's it feels
really interlink but it's also going
back to the media thing it's really
interesting how when all the protests
started going down and that become
becomes the number one news story that
you're seeing and the headlines every
day everybody's like oh so coronaviruses
over we consume so much social media
just gradual media it's like that is how
that is are like our reality is shaped
so much by the stuff we read so it's
like if you see covet headlines every
day you're like oh my god I got to stay
inside like this is the worst thing ever
and then as soon as something else pops
off in the news you're like well what
are we even worried about I mean it does
show you that there is some sense of
cohesion um but this brings up another
like deeper problem that we were talking
about with Freddie
again on when we were filming which is
like the idea of well there's two things
happening you know first first of all
there's there's that there's the ad
revenue click-through based media model
yes and that's been which is been awful
for like it's been good information one
of the worst things to happen to us in
the 21st century I would I think at the
end of the day when we when people look
back and they analyze this time they're
gonna be like yeah one of the worst
things that happened was the
decentralization of information
unilaterally not centralized based on a
or a person but centralized based on
truth hmm
because you're just you're clinging to
cliffs yeah the money you get the money
you make the article you know it's all
about the headline you play that game
but we're not out there like you know
reporting on the Mueller Investigation
Captain America's cool new shield like
it affects literally everything right
now like affects information in a
completely radical way where it's like
it's everything from the protests to you
know the coronavirus to just everyday
news because it begins to incentivize
people to like not write accurate
headlines for articles and like
headlines are important because they
draw you in and give you an overview of
what the article is going to eventually
tell you more about and it's like you
know you start looking at every
everything coronavirus it's like all
right well we have a small phenomenon or
an offshoot that affected ten people but
we're gonna put it as a headline like
this is then this is the next phase of
it yeah it's like Piketon but it was
like in one apartment building yeah it
spikes here or there's there's ooh
symptom that happen yeah sounds really
nasty but it affected like five people
yeah and it's like not a thing that and
they're all related yeah and and then
even like the protest things too it's
like you know we we're getting this
condensed like like in like exaggerated
version of things through everyone who
do don't support the protest to everyone
who do support it you know you have to
you start taking these like over-the-top
extreme positions on stuff to seem like
oh well like this is more relevant in
it's like here's the information you
need to know now versus like thirty
seconds ago a twitter yeah or something
like that and then even like I saw this
thing about like there's like a kind of
a breakdown of like the the it was kind
of like a post mortem of a couple like
cancelled culture style things that
happened lately
yeah and showed how like an event
happened and then how like multiple
tweets and articles basically end up
spinning one thing and turning it from
like one person makes an off-color joke
now you get the whole like
person's a racist article yeah which is
like like there's you know it's there's
like it's not it's not functional but
that headline is more like boom yeah
your world is about to get turned upside
down here's something you you need to
know and you you need to know about this
person that just happened to jenna
Marbles yeah well really yeah she's like
just for you to just just bowed out of
youtube for indefinitely really because
because six years ago she did a Nicki
Minaj video she was a brown Tanner on
yeah and and people called it blackface
and so then they said that she backed
out of YouTube or she that that she she
quit because of her blackface video yeah
she was already super tan at the time
first of all she's used to impersonate
everybody her whole shtick was
impersonating people and she did a Nicki
Minaj one like what literally had
nothing to do with Nicki Minaj being
being black and look I mean obviously we
don't have like Jordan or West so I'm in
this conversations which would help
bring a little more context to it but
like there's a clear blackface is one
thing yes changing the color of your
skin tone for the sake of reenacting or
portraying another person isn't
blackface like as much as wearing a wig
is bright red playing someone with long
red hair you're a red hair yeah you know
you're making you know it's like I mean
uh blackface is specifically a
historically and culturally racist thing
that was done when white people
re-enacted African Americans slash
blacks whatever you want to their term
seems to be fluctuating with just blacks
now I think black people whatever
doesn't matter point is that context
matters we're not like this is one
specific thing where they basically do
this over-the-top makeup a make-up
effect on a white person to make fun of
that community right and and it's not
just a superficial not superficially
doing something to your body to resemble
another person you know it's like and
that distinction is like so like it's
lost though at this I'm using the jenna
marbles example as a great example of
how that got twisted also it was
something that she had even I believe
might be wrong on this but I believe
she had private 'add that video since
then like she was already like a people
might see this the wrong way I'm gonna
take it down mmm
and even yeah it's it's like that
it's that inability now for people to
have changed or if grown you know what I
mean we're right yeah it's but it's kind
of this weird thing with the culture
where it's like the pendulum is swinging
the other way from where it used to be
and now it's kind of overextended and
now we're digging into people's past and
saying and saying you know this thing
this is the thing though it's like
because we've been making videos for so
long now like we're starting to hit that
like threshold or even ourselves of like
like what like what did we do like we're
totally different than we were 10 years
ago yeah but the evidence of what we
were like ten years ago still remains
and you know it's like can that
separation be made anymore for people
whose lives have been recorded online
and I think it's it's tough because I
mean I think there's that benefit of the
doubt that you should give people yeah
and like alright well that was a long
time ago people are different and it's
like if this is like today or last year
or something that feels very recent
relevant it's like yeah sure call them
out but like once you start hitting that
like six seven eight years it's like
whoa it's like not to mention look like
Jimmy Kimmel did you know he person a
damn basting him a black basketball
player come on man show Jimmy Fallon did
it - what is it the Wayans brothers did
white face in a movie yeah they did a
whole movie you know it's like it's like
look guys you know this was all
culturally accepted and I mean well hold
on actually you can't go down that path
because blackface was culturally
accepted at one point - by a certain
group but you know it's still one it's
like well I guess it's anger man every
critic there's a lot of people who are
really angry right now and it's coming
out a lot of different ways how people
want to do something about it and that's
coming out in different ways and the
easiest way to do something about
something is to get angry online like
yeah that's just a lot of people do that
and like I'm not trying to rag on people
for like posting things there's social
media like I
it's not what I'm trying to say here but
like it's easy to feel like you have
done something good when you up vote or
share or post a story and it can be a
good thing but like it's it's easy to
fall into the trap of that becoming a
self-indulgent
activity even talking about it is almost
the same thing like even though it's
what we're doing right now of this
impotent rage against this group of
people
his nameless Anonymous group of people
who go after people for what you know
it's like I even get react like I'm
starting to see that too it's like wait
a second Joe Rogan is almost cancelled
culture too because he's just
complaining about canceled culture but
it's like it's the same thing like who's
who's the complainer you know like it's
it's it's yeah so for me it really goes
our on it out there it like keeps going
back to that thing of like how much
people's lives are shaped by the
internet now so it's like if it's that
you know Twitter people on Twitter is
like 2% of the population and then how
much of that like how much of people on
Twitter are engaging in this kind of
stuff you know what I mean
but that's the stuff that gets put in
news articles and CNN and stuff so that
sorry go ahead but it enters your it
enters your you know we only have so
much space in our base nailed needle
brain to like you know put stuff in and
like if you know who looked at their
screen time and saw that you know how
many hours you've been spending on your
phone like that's that negatively
affects you and I'm sure like the huge
uptick and like depression and anxiety
all that stuff is like it's gotta be at
least partially tied to just the amount
of like negative yeah like I got off
Twitter like two years ago
and that's I'm just so so much more
happy like being away from and I wasn't
even like I wasn't too engaged in it but
you just scroll through your feet and
you see all this anger and stuff and
it's just like how it takes man
yeah I hear ya I don't really do Twitter
or I mean I have Twitter and Facebook
profile really really yeah I had a
breeze like you know I wonder if I
should get back into Twitter and
like is mostly just the thing of like I
was talking with Renan Ren has had a
totally different experience on Twitter
than most people because you know the
people he interacts with don't dive into
this garbage and so like you know his
version of Twitter is like very
different and I was like I know this is
pretty positive I would like to be able
to kind of connect with more people but
then like the moment I like tweeted
something that was opinionated it was
like it was like eight positive comments
and then to just like just garbage
comments and that I don't know so I
stopped I was like no I I made the right
call not using Twitter and yeah it
wasn't these days it wasn't like a it
wasn't like I don't know like no one
respected the opinion as an opinion and
responded with their own you know yeah
like it's more like no not here's not
another opinion that maybe counters that
but it's like here's why your opinion is
wrong or more no just the statement your
opinion is wrong you know like yeah not
even your opinion just you're wrong yeah
actually kind of goes deeper and you're
a bad person
yeah this goes back to my point about
the the way that we currently are taking
on information with with all across the
world you know through through
journalism and all that stuff
now I'm just gonna throw this out there
what if there was a subscription model
to news media to journalism
I mean you can sign you subscribe to a
New York Times yes but but it's like
YouTube it's like people have been
trained to expect that everything is
gonna be free so as long as like as long
as there are free news outlets out there
people are just gonna turn to this you
know I mean but it's like you could get
the New York Times Washington I could
always I don't know who runs the
Associated Press if I was the the
Council of of Illuminati that runs there
people that ran The Associated Press I
would look around and I'd say hey look
we we have all these journalists we
create all this information for all
these different outlets which then also
gets duplicated across additional
outlets yeah
right because the the thing about it
that and and I would say here's how this
might still make a difference because
even though you would have the problem
of free media or free news under a
subscription model if an organization
like The Associated Press created a true
subscription model that that paid for
that that that was overwhelmingly paying
for the cost to create that information
based on you know accurate reporting and
the traditional techniques the way that
most news information works is people
will follow one person on on an on a
topic so for example if it's you know
yeah Sam's guitar I was gonna say
something like this too
so there'll be one guy that's like the
guy that's writing or gal that's writing
on Sam's guitar and then everybody else
will pick up that and say okay Sam's
guitar is this color and it's got these
strings and it's got this these frets
and I know they'll reiterate all those
facts so you might see some trickle down
into that even if there was free models
and yeah well like in like even a thing
though it's like I think the problem
right now is that like it's because of
the decentralization of all this
information and the way it's the way
it's affected previous like news
institutions it's it's kind of like hard
to I guess when you see the subscription
for like Washington Post or New York
Times it's like well it's like is this
like am I feeling like this is really
gonna be valuable at this point like
this institution like the news source at
this point because if it's decentralized
the way it kind of is right now it's
like almost more about the people who
you trust to report it like it's almost
individuals at this point rather than
institutions that are guided by this
like concept of the news cycle you know
like we even stuck in like late 90s or
90s early 2000s like pre you know
decentralization of this information
where it's like even like the even cable
news channels fell into their like
version of this rhythm and so it's like
you know if there was some sort of like
a network where it's like alright I will
subscribe it to you to make sure you
aggregate good writers and I don't care
what platform they're posting these
stories on I don't care what news source
it's coming from the main thing is is
that I want trustworthy people who have
were able to provide insight on topics
right and it's like I would subscribe to
that that's what I feel like right now
it's like most of my news is coming from
people individuals whose opinions I
respect and like I trust to do their due
diligence when speaking about a topic
and whether that's making sure they
correct errors making sure they say
things reasonably or fair yeah it's not
even just like the opinions they hold
but just yeah can can you can you like
honestly convey information to me well I
feel like on the flip side of what we've
been talking about that is kind of the
beautiful and positive thing about the
decentralization cuz it leaves the
option or the choice in people's hands
to instead of blindly following that one
you know you know the traditional source
you seek out people but um it's just an
interesting thing because it's like
that's what's happening across all media
film TV every you know I had a
conversation with somebody where they
were like I'm you know he was older and
he's like I miss the days where you
could just flip through channels and he
kind of the choices made for you you
know what I mean like it's whatever's on
you know CBS you're just watching but
now it's like in our lives we have to
choose especially my generation I feel
like we grew up basically having to
choose everything we're consuming and
it's a weird dilemma because human
beings are not we're not wired that way
to be constantly choosing what we're
doing in every moment yeah or at least
like you know in terms of you know
constructing your narrative a little bit
you know another thing like that
remember it's like you know we're all we
do media thing we're in YouTube etc like
we know these people like I've met jenna
marbles you know it's like yeah mostly
people they're just characters they're
just another character that lives only
on the computer screen
and I'm not saying that people don't see
these people as not being people
actually yeah I'm kind of saying that
I'm saying if there's a lot of people
that don't see these people as real
people you know they see them as
characters and then they see them as a
representation of the thing that they
hate right it's like you know if you
you're not aware of her or anybody else
that's getting canceled at all and then
they pop into your feet as like this
person is a white supremacist you know
whatever it is and then you just now
it's a bad guy yeah you're just like
okay I'm gonna delete them list from my
list yeah yeah yeah no there's
definitely that I mean I think the best
just to turn this a little bit more
positively like the best thing that I've
been doing lately in terms of like
trying to seek and seek and understand
accurate information is just reading
multiple sources yeah yeah and firsthand
sources yeah firsthand like you know
three to four at least cuz you can't you
can't just do Fox and CNN that's also
flies oh yeah
the wires are pretty good so like
Reuters and ApS yeah I did that exercise
that first hand exercise for about like
two weeks three weeks when like the
virus starting to spread the lockdown
was happening right yeah I listened to
the White House press briefings and I
had read like the news articles written
off the press briefings yeah and the
disconnect between those and like
materially yes the amount of times like
you know my little critical thinking
buzzers went off yeah like what I see
those two and it's like look these guys
are just they're watching the same press
conference I am and they're writing this
article and the amount of assumptions
statements selective editing and all
that kind of stuff happening or it's
like poof man if it's like this now oh
yeah how is it like all that like
looking back over the years all those
articles all the segments like it's all
over the place man they're doing that
with the president every day I mean to
say that he doesn't have really really
bad moments not to say that he doesn't
have a lack of decorum because he has
all of those things and and more
definitely something that he needs to
work on but you know just that fourth of
July speech at at Mount Rushmore I
watched it and I was like okay well you
know I see this I and I listen to this
guy speak for an hour I understand what
he said and
I went and read the articles that were
based on it I was like man there's a lot
of these same thing you know just cherry
picking and and you know yeah context
man yeah you can I I always noticed like
anytime someone like tells you like what
happened but they refuse to give you a
little bit of context I would really
clarify it it's like that's a that's a
telltale sign that like people are
warping the information a little bit
yeah
I'm curious how much screen time do you
guys have in your phone as a daily
average I got a check probably it's
pretty high right now there's all of
apples I don't know if I can check I
feel like everybody's shot up during
mine without more attention I mean
obviously we're working from home so
when I mean time under settings like an
eco beat I got yeah he's got a better
record two hours 37 minutes I'm at 3
hours 38 minutes a day to 21 average
four oh four hours five minutes oh wow
I'm a Gorsky I'm sitting there with the
freaking baby and I am just in there I
do not have that on my little my little
boy over here Christian what do you got
245 the question
that's not bad honestly you guys if you
think about like in the past like people
what used to watch like an average four
hours of TV a day I don't really watch I
watched like 20 minutes of TV like well
I watched my one episode of community a
day on Netflix and that's it then it's
all my phone from there yeah you know
you know just to I don't want to I don't
want to leave people feeling negative
here so I just I want to say something
about how to stay positive you know
there might be all this stuff inside of
here right right but if you if you do
this and you go okay just throw your
phone away for those of you who aren't
watching this video you throw your phone
over there and you go out and you look
around yeah the amount does the amount
of information that you're taking in fit
all of the narratives that you're
reading yeah don't forget to just look
at the world they're going to and draw
your judgments from that too right cuz I
came to LA on Sunday you know and
stepped out Monday morning when Mario
hit his little kid his little bell on
the taco
still easy coming back now 8:30 every
day man right out there to get a
breakfast burrito and I was like it's
pretty nice morning down here
they said la it was full of rioters and
like you know crazy people and you know
this is pretty nice there's some guys
working this guy's got a taco truck
these guys are smoking weed down the
street it's funny how much a few blocks
makes a difference that's true that's
true but yeah I am I mean I went
downtown last time to the to the city
it's kind of crazy we've been going out
for dinner
yeah like Fridays wherever's you know
outdoor seating it's been great but we
went to a place in downtown and it was
like creepy as hell it was it was dead
silent in the middle of downtown
everything was boarded up and we're
walking around like crazy like people
are like you know no it's just like
eerie and apocalyptic and then we're
like yeah Wow we are clearly out of
touch I went to one wailing with Jan and
Ren and we went down toward City Hall
last time I was here and it was
definitely a different scene than hunter
Street at 8:30 in the morning yeah yeah
sure he's gotten busy yeah good times
things aren't things aren't that bad
they're not that's the important thing
and they're pretty bad for like 10
percent of people right now it's really
freaking sucks
yeah but they could be a lot worse we
could be in a world war like for food
I'm like 20 percent tip you deserve
every penny right I'm coming back all
I'm tipping those people way too much
yeah like it's just probably Bissman I
know that's how I feel now I'm like yeah
it's like as much as we can give right
now yeah like we're not we're not
breaking quarantine we're supporting the
economy I think the moral of this story
is like people need a place to to vent
in to talk and to let off steam and
that's become a lot of the internet
right now and it's it's not always a
healthy place to be and you should take
some time and look around you and spend
some time in real life
and see the people and talk to people to
have conversations where people aren't
inspired to just throw the hottest takes
at you the moment the moment you set
eyes upon them yeah and and realize that
maybe around you there's still some good
things actually no what no no that
pansy-ass like talking about look around
you and there are good things around you
and you should appreciate it and enjoy
it and savor it because that's livin
that's living that's livin comes and
goes yeah
and you know what like young Dean over
here young Dean speaking of living
6:38 my child goes to bed in 45 minutes
i I better get home all right basil yeah
all right all right
slurping dirt boys
[Laughter]
[Music]